when i say psychopaths
never belong being out on the street
again ever
well i don't want that guy living next
to you can you
define what it makes what it takes for a
person to be a psychopath what
characteristics how do you test
zero empathy zero
compassion will cut your [ __ ] head
off and go to sleep
i know a guy who stabbed the guy his
cellmate and went back
to bed killed him and went to sleep
there's another guy who cut a guy's head
off in prison with a shank
these two inmates and another inmate
poor guy only had 10-year sentence and
he was getting out he's a bank robber
they were in a cell they put three in a
cell
they put three guys in a cell they cut
him
open these two guys had life they cut
him open they took his intestines out
and it wrapped his intestines around the
door
i consider that a psychopath is this the
prison that you were in yeah
holy [ __ ] dude i consider that
psychopaths
now you could look them up you could
look these into yeah they're very easily
what i talk about i always tell people
you don't even have to [ __ ] believe
me i lived it
go look it up and you'll be able to
google it yeah
so the the violent level now that now
again
what are you uh going back to the
psychopath how does someone become that
how do you i don't think they're born
with that how do you think that's it's
like childhood trauma
well i think there's a lot of factors
that go into it i think what happens is
you know i hate to say this i i think i
could become a psychopath if i lived in
it
i don't know if you did what if i if i
if if i lived in that environment long
enough or
uh i don't know maybe i couldn't maybe i
couldn't because
there's something deep [ __ ] seeded
yeah i always
even when i was a criminal i used to
give money to people and i i cared about
people i always did
i always had a heart right you know i
often talk to parents
you know and i do a lot with parents and
families and i and they'll ask me you
know
i want to talk to the kid once i find
out certain questions
you know he hates his parents he hates
his sister
but you find out he loves cats or loves
dogs or something
he's got he's savable he's got that
compassion he's got that empathy in him
now you got to get it out
you got to direct it but then you get
the really psychos maybe you know like
you said
for whatever reason no one's home
nobody's home i'm telling you i've seen
their eyes their black
eyes and and what you can almost see in
this song there's nothing
it's [ __ ] dark and those people i
i've
ate with them talked with them hung out
with them and you don't think i ever
trusted him not for a [ __ ] second
i don't want that guy cutting out living
next to you
so i'm not a bleeding heart everybody
gets out of prison
it has to be you know the right people
but we have too many people in prison
who do change you take myself and i have
to tell young people
when you're 20 ryan yeah you think you
know it all
i'm not gonna love them then you hit 30
and you say [ __ ] i didn't know [ __ ] at
20. when you hit
40 it's gonna be [ __ ] i didn't know [ __ ]
at 30. when you hit 50 you're gonna say
am i ever gonna [ __ ] learn anything
i'm gonna hit
60 and i'm learning every day yeah
because you change
you change your views you change your
things and i'm i'm i'm a ver
i am uh very uh i get i'm very socially
liberal
very socially liberal uh
and somewhat fiscally conservative i
still don't care what no matter what no
person in this country should have to
eat cat food i don't give a [ __ ] what
she did wrong
or her husband left her and they didn't
put enough and she stole i don't give a
[ __ ]
nobody should eat cat food in this
country or any country we should be able
to feed people and i don't care how that
has to happen
but i don't believe we should just give
money just give money for lazy people
i'm not lazy
right you're not lazy obviously and i
think
uh we need to that's my views that's why
i'm
a libertarian but i believe i think all
drugs should be legal
uh they've done this experiments now and
and now in
oregon you know drugs are now oh you're
criminalized did you know
muscle mushrooms and stuff in dc is
legalized
and it should be you're not going to
hurt i mean what are you going to do
you're getting you drink a [ __ ] fifth
of vodka and go drive down the street
but you can't eat a magic mushroom
absolutely see
my point is if you commit a crime to get
the drug
that you should be held accountable
right if you're robbing somebody do
be held accountable but what you do in
your own hand i have to tell people you
want to go on your [ __ ]
bedroom jack off in the corner up
against have fun do whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do it's your house your
place
you shouldn't infringe on other people's
mm-hmm but do what you want
that's what freedom is that's true
freedom and we don't have it right now
we don't have it a lot of people oh we
live in the freest country in the world
wait a minute 96 countries
not 196 countries have freedom total
freedom
much is us so it's not
do i love america absolutely and then
again going back to
196 countries have freedom but we have
more people locked up than any other
country
so exactly so how free are we at what
at what degree are we overstepping our
bounds as a country yes we need
government yes we need
uh roads fixed and you know the
government was originally formed and i'm
a history nut was
especially like the navy and the
military and the coast guard was
actually the first
of service ever out is because we wanted
to protect waterways and we wanted to
protect free trade
that's a that's a government function we
want to defend ourselves against another
country that's
what we need but we don't need
government in your business
you know like the sheriff who wants to
show these [ __ ] people who
wrote a bad check and now they're
[ __ ] the biggest villain in their own
wheel of fugitive and
wheel whatever the [ __ ] he calls it
that's
such a degrading thing how much [ __ ]
things did he do wrong
that guy right if he really wants to be
honest with himself
now i'm not saying you can't get again
to get him but you don't gotta
humiliate him on a [ __ ] [ __ ]
wheel of thing
now if the guy's a murderer a [ __ ]
you want help getting a murderer that's
kill the [ __ ] kid absolutely you know
you know there's crimes that we we
should all be pissed at
what happened at the capitol right
[ __ ] treason
right i don't care what people trumpers
or whatever the [ __ ] they are
i don't give a [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
treason that
that was i'm it's beyond words for me
i listened to how would stern today go
off really oh what was he saying about
it [ __ ]
thinks he's [ __ ] nuts people should
be in jail prison all this said they're
brainwashed
and they are it's [ __ ] crazy scary
[ __ ] scary crazy and and those are
the things
that that we should be here uh pissed at
and we should be pissing a murderer or
me i was a [ __ ] criminal i'm being
honest i was a robber i was
not good i belonged in prison did i
belong to be strapped down naked a guy
take his dick out and pee on my face
without me wanting it
i'm joking you know my point is it's
wrong i mean i was wrong then and and
and those are the crimes that should be
held accountable and go to prison
yes the guy wrote the check right and
the credit they're wrong
but do they need to be humiliated on a
wheel future fugitive
violation of probation what was his
probation you find out he [ __ ]
he [ __ ] got six-month probation for
[ __ ] driving on suspended license
i was just gonna say that you know
multiple drop
but now he's on the wheel of fugitive do
we really need to [ __ ] goddamn
humiliate people
i don't believe so
i